- [Nicole] We grew up
with only cheap doughnuts
because nobody had gourmet
doughnuts back then.
I'd have to say that I
prefer the classic stuff,
like, simple is better.
Smell-wise I can tell
you it smells the most
fake a doughnut could possibly smell.
It also happens to look
like a little butthole.
It's nice and yellow.
I mean, obviously, like everyone
who grew up in the eighties and nineties
has eaten one of these things.
It leaves a greasy film
on the roof of my mouth
which makes me sad.
It seems like it might be, like,
formed by some sort of,
like, injection gun.
It's like foam inside.
It's weird.
I'm gonna give this two, a two stars.
It looks like it came out of a package
and it smells like some sort of weird oil.
I wanna say that this is like palm oil.
That's really bad and like,
killing the rain forest.
Ah, so this doughnut feels,
like, soggy on the bottom
and a little bit wet.
I'm gonna take a really small bite
'cause I'm not hopeful.
'Cause it smells pretty bad.
It's super gross.
But it has that one
weird old school flavor
where it's, like, fake
lemon and artificial nutmeg.
It's both kind of, like, endearing
and also really disgusting.
Kind of like diet coke.
One star.
This doughnut is from Winchell's
and it's really (beep) beautiful.
Like it's the most beautiful doughnut
I've seen in a long time.
So, what you look for when
you're making a yeasted doughnut
which is this risen glazed doughnut
is that this line forms because
the dough has risen at the proper time
and developed in a way
where it's gonna cook
evenly on both sides.
But you can see the spice in here.
I don't know if this is
the most expensive doughnut
you bought but, like,
damn, it's pretty good.
This is probably the
peak of cheap doughnuts
and it's a five star doughnut.
Kudos to this doughnut person.
They really did a great job.
So, this is a Dunkin' Donuts
raised glazed doughnut.
It smells almost like nothing
which is really weird.
Okay, so it smells really--
It smells like it's got
some fake stuff in it.
Like, fake vanilla.
It's got a good texture, though, in terms
of, like, the squish and stuff.
But there's a really odd bitter flavor.
This doughnut probably gets, like, a two.
Probably the most hyped
doughnut in America.
I have to say I'm a little
disappointed by this doughnut
because it looks really flat
and it feels really tight
like either it's stale or that the person
proofing the dough did not do a great job.
The glaze it super thick.
It almost feels like it's made out of wax.
The inside of the dough has, like,
no character at all.
It's really white also.
Basically, this is if you took wonderbread
and fried it and then put glaze on it.
It pains me to say it, a one star.